まああの これからこの決して失わ失われない財産というテーマで
1つの経典をあの紹介したいと思います
いろいろ誤字とかあると思いますけどね
まあそれはまあその場で自分で直しちゃいけないんですね
まあそういうことで まあ財産と言っても
まあいわゆる裏切れない財産ということですね
まあその財産という言葉についてブッダが何を語ったのかということで
まあとりあえず初期仏教の世界は理解できるし
お釈迦様はすごい具体的に物事を教えているんだっていうこともわかるんですね
まあ特別な信仰する宗教ではなくて
ではまあ早速話に入ります
ではアンブッタリカエトゥテキストにウッガスッタ
ウッガスッタンという経典の名前なんですね
ウッガ経 小集部経典に入ってます
まあページ番号はこの6番目のじゃなくて4番目の100ページに入ってます
はい それからこの話に入る前に
あの財産 まあそれに対して定義してみましょう
財産といえば何でしょうか
まあまず人間が必要としているものですね
必要でなきゃ財産と言えませんだからね
人間にとってはそれは必要なんですね
それは大事なポイントなんですよ
財産を要りませんとか何とか言えてる場合じゃないんで
必要なものですからね
それで財産の種類は2つあります
あまり世の中で考えないんですけど
仏教ははっきりとこの2つに分けてみるんですね
財産は  1番目は外界の財産
まあ外の財産ですね バーヒラというパーリ語を使ってますけどね
まあ具体的に言えば 財貨
家族 親族 親友など それからそのその他の生き物
まあ牛やらペットやらニワトリやらいろいろですね
まあそれは財産なんですね
まあだからいろいろと言ったっても
例えばパンダが自分の財産と言えば全然我々の財産じゃないんですけどね
まあ我々にとっては自分が飼ってるペットやらね
あるいは牛とかね 養鶏場とか作ってる
まあ商売してるならば
その生き物は財産になるんですね
でっかいあの牛のファームを経営しているんだからといって
動物園のパンダも自分の財産と思ったら
それはちょっと勘違いです
ね  それは まあ別に特別に個人の財産じゃないんです
そういうふうに財産 この外のものというものあるんですね
自分の子供でも外のものなんですね
だからなんで外のものだと分けたんですかね
子供にしたっても 勝手に動いたりしてるでしょうに
勝手に生きてるでしょうに
だから自分の子供なのにそう簡単に管理できないんですよ
だから自分飼ってるペットだからといって自分の希望通りに動くってこともない
だからこの外のものっていうことは外界のものであると
子供から持ってるお金やら
すべて外界のものであるということをはっきりした方がいいんです
それはっきりすると かなりこれ知識なんというか
理性なんですよ 正しい考え方なんです
私のお金であっても 私には自由に使うということはできないんですよ
と言うだけで で 他人に管理してしまっちゃうんですよ
ですから この外界のものということはね
よく覚えた方がいいんですけど
内界の財産というのは知識
能力 技術 まあ容姿などですね
例えばすごい美しい人がいて
それが財産で それで結構幸せに生きているんだと
言うと 美しさっていうのは
まあ自分の体にあるものだから
まあ内界に入っちゃうんですね
例えば自分の銀行口座を誰かカラクリして全部お金取っちゃっても
美しい人がその美しさで生きてるならば
それは持っていかれませんね
とは言っても それでも誰かなんとか攻撃したりしてね
あの体の美しさを壊してしまうということもありえないわけでもないんですね
例えば 美しい声を持って生まれる人は
それも能力なんですね
それはそう簡単には誰かに管理することはできないんだけど
まあだからといってずっと自分を守ってくれるということでもないんです
知識にしたってもね まあいつでも使えるものじゃないし
まあ衰えていったりはするしね
まあ能力もそういうことでね
そういうふうに財産は 2つに分けてみるんですね
分けてみると 外界の財産よりはいくらか自分の外界の財産はまあいくらか安全といえば安全なんだ
何か技術を学んだ人がベースに
まあどこへ行ったっても
その技術も身についたものは自分のものだからね
そう簡単になくなることもないんでしょうね
だからこの中でどちらかというと
人間 この財産 2つの中で確実に身についた方がいいといえば 2番目なんですね
といっても 養殖というのはちょっとまあ生まれつきついてないとできないということもあるんですね
それで財産の特色に行きます
経済学で人間の欲望を満たし満足させ
人間が支配処分できる物質という定義になるんですね
それで皆様はそれはよく学んでいると思います
経済学ということは で
人間の欲望を満足させるさせて
また人間が支配処分できる物質
それは財産になるんですね
それで世の中で財というものはその側面でのみ評価しているんですね
だから 優れたノーベル賞まで取る経済学者がいるかもしれませんだけど
経済学者が財について見ているの見方がたった一つなんですね
人間の欲望を満足させるもの
それから人間に支配できる
処分できるものであると
物事の 1つの側面だけを見て決めることは
仏教の見方ではありません
仏教は何を見ても 1つの側面だけで見るということはしないんですね
もうあらゆるすべての側面から見るんですね
裏も表も全部見るんですね
全部見てから評価するんです
世間では 1側面だけ 例えば原子爆弾を作ったら
それで原子力を持っている大国になるんだよと
それだけ では作りましょうということになるんですね
それだけで物事を評価しません
まあ例えば原子力を持っている国々はいくつか何かがありますけど
だけど何か得になってますかね
それで アメリカはすごいたくさん持って
んだからといって これ原子爆弾を落とすことを誰も落とすことできんでしょうね
だったら持ったも持ってなくたってもどうでも同じことでしょうに
しかし 愚か者たちだから
やっぱり持つべきであると
と思っちゃうんです 中国が原子爆弾を持ってるんだからって
どこかに落とせる？それは
だから この世の中の知識人という人々はそういう程度なんですね
物事の一側面だけ見て
行動するんです それは仏教的な見方じゃないんですね
いろんな側面で見なくちゃいけないんですね
財の機能は欲を満たすだけではありません
特色はいくつかあります
それで仏教から見れば
財っていうのは我々の欲を満たしてくれるだけじゃないんです
また 他の仕事もしているんです
それはこれから勉強してみましょう
一 必要 まあ第一は必要ということで
それでも丸を入れた方がいいんですけどね
まあ財産 財はやっぱり必要なものなんですね
それから欲を満たすではなく
欲に応じてくれる 仏教から見れば欲を満たしてくれないんですよ
欲になんとなく応じてくれる
応じるだけで満たすっていうことじゃないんです
この意味はすごく違うんです
満たす なんとなく応じる
特にペットの場合は 自分の希望とか何でもかんでも満たしてくれますかね
くれないでしょ その代わりにいくらか応じてはくれます
犬さんにはいつでもお手と言ったたびに手を出してくれるわけじゃないんです
機嫌が悪い時もあります
呼んでも無視される時もあります
だからペットも財産でしょうね
ペットは自分の欲望を満たしてくれると
ただ そうじゃないんです
応じてくれる だからこの経済学者は満たすという satisfy
という単語使いますけど
仏教は使いません  それだけでも仏教の世界はすごく変わると思います
そこでちょっと説明しますけど
経済学ではこの unlimited needs という単語がありますね
日本語になってくるとどうあまりわからないんだけど
そのまま英語の単語書きましたけど
人間の needs は unlimited
無制限にあるんだと というが
仏教的には limited needs なんですよ
人間には数え切れないほど欲望あるわけじゃないんです
それも間違いなんです
limited needs なんですよ
どんな人にでもどれぐらい欲望あるのかというと
ちゃんとした量があるんです
例えば皆様にこの 何と言いますか
アイススケーティングでオリンピックの金メダル取りたいという欲望ありますか？まあ
正気な人だったらないと思いますけど
そんな欲望は あるいは収入はよろしいんだから
あの日本の芸能界でアイドルになりたいとか
昔あったかもしれませんだけど
今になったら全くその欲望はないでしょうに
だから人間の欲望は限りなくあるんじゃなくて
いつでもリミットがあるんですよ
その時点での経済学は
仏教から見るとえらい偏見な学問なんですね
ですが それなのに満たせない cannot
satisfy 欲望はそれほどたくさんないんですよ
我々には 問題はその欲望自体が満たせないということなんです
だから unlimited needs と limited means の間のからくりが経済学であるというんですよ
定義からも間違ってますよ Limited
meansなんですけど
そのLimited meansは満たすことはできないんだから
経済学は入れなくなるんです
本当は要りませんよ 何もやってくれませんだからね
みんな頑張って経済状況が良くなってくると
経済学者はいろいろ数字を持ってきて
これぐらい経済成長しているんだとかね
これぐらいになるんだとか
数字持ってるだけでしょうに
そんなことはあってもなくてもどうでもいいでしょう
株が上がったり下がったりすると
なぜ上がっているのか
なぜ下がっているのかと分析するでしょ
でも 株の売買で生計を立てている人にとっては何の役にも立ちませんよ
なんだか会社については噂流れたんだから
ドーンと株が下落しましたと
今更言ったっても 損しているはもうとっくに損しているんでしょうに
だから必死になってみんなこれ読んだりしているでしょうね
私は英字新聞を一応読んではというか
開けては見るんですけど
一番読みやすい真ん中のページ 4つぐらいかな
全部もう株の情報でうるさくてしょうがない
もう大事な記事っていうのは別な別なところであって
読みにくいんですね だからもう本当にいらん学問だと言いたいところなんですよ
簡単には手に入らない
ほら 財っていうのはそう簡単に自分のものにならないんですよ
必要ですよ 欲があるんだから
例えば独身の人は結婚したいと思ったりする
別にそれは不自然な欲望ですけど
だからってそう簡単にはいかないんですね
その人にはアンリミテッドじゃないんですよ
一人の人と結婚すれば十分なんです
若い人々は 10人ぐらいと結婚したいとか誰も思わないんです
みんな探してるのは自分にぴったし気に入っている一人の人に出会いたいだけというすごい小さな欲望でしょうに
なんでそれにアンリミテッド無制限にと言うんでしょうかね
問題はすごい小さな希望なんですけど
性格も合う気に入っている人と一緒になりたいと
これがうまくいかないことなんですよ
それで性格の合う人と一緒になっても満足はできませんね
いろいろ問題が起きてくる
それが本当の状況なんです
だからこの世の中は狂ってますよ
もうこういう間違ってる思考で動いてますから
とにかく簡単に手に入らないということで
人間にはあらゆる苦しみが生まれてくるんですよ
手に入らないんだから
もうもう手段を選ばもう自分の欲望だから頑張らなくちゃいかんでしょうに
戦わなくちゃいかんでしょうに
これがすごい苦しみに苦難になっちゃうんですよ
失望に陥ったりするし
失敗もしたりするし ものすごく人を怒ったり
ライバル意識持ったりしなくちゃ
もう苦しまなくちゃいけないし
そうやって財はもうそんなもんなんですね
正しく見れば 苦の原理になりますよ
苦悩の原因になります
競争しなくてはならないんですね
財っていうのはほとんど外のものなんですよ
外のものだから みんな自分自分で欲しがるでしょうね
そこで競争っていうものが成り立っちゃうんですね
競争することはそんなに面白いことじゃないんです
競争しちゃうと明らかに凶暴な人が余分に取っちゃうし
気が弱い人にとっては必要な分もなくなっちゃうんですね
競争する凶暴な人も苦難に陥るし
必要なものさえ手に入らない人もなおさら苦難に陥ったりするんですよ
それが事実ですよ 経済世界では
だから苦難の原因になる
それから苦労して得ても得たものを守る
維持する 補給することが必要なんですね
で 自分に必要なものを得たとします
もう戦って頑張って もうあらゆる苦しみを経て
何とか財産を自分のものにしたとする
しても それは守らなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 財産は外のものなんですよ
みんなそれに競争してるんですよ
得ようとして だから他人にとらわれないようにと守らなくちゃいかないし
それだけではなくて維持しなくちゃいけないし
補給しなくちゃいけないし
一回例えば一回畑を作って収穫をもらってもらいまったでいっぱい
我々は幸福だと言っていられる場合じゃないんですよ
この収穫したものは減っていくんだから
で また畑を作って また補給しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからそういうこともね
財産を得てもそれで終わらないんです
仕事が だから苦難の原因になるんですね
執着が必然的に起こるんです
財産には苦労して得たものだから
必ずもそれには執着はするんです
執着しないでいることは不可能なんです
自分が夢見て夢見ていたものは
買ったならば 買ってとればそれにそれには執着する
待望の子供が生まれてきたら
その子供にすごく執着する
気に入った仕事に仕事を見つけたら
その仕事に執着する 執着しない
どうやっているんですかね
いられませんよ 執着したっていうことは
そのものから離れなくなるんです
したがって 自由が失うんです
振り回されるんです 確実にそうなるでしょ
金がたくさんある人は金に振り回されるし
欲しがった子供が生まれてきたら子供に振り回される
自由がなくなっちゃうんです
人間が支配するものであったはずなのに
逆に支配されてしまうんです
ものすごい大変ですなことになるんです
これが苦難なんですよ
経済学者の人間が支配するものであると
あれは嘘なんです 実際の世界では
財産が人間を支配しているんです
振り回されているんです
逆になってます 結果として生き方が狂ってしまう
だから 人間の生き方は全部一般的に言えば狂っているんです
皆様に興味あるのは北朝鮮のことだからね
皆様から見れば狂ってるでしょう
で 日本で流している一方的な情報から見ると
まあ韓国の北朝鮮というと
食べるものもなくて ものすごく苦しんで
もうもう薬もなくて死にかけている
なのに もう軍隊にだけ全て収入を使っている
すごい金かかって あのミサイルなんかはすごい金かかるんですよ
そこで定期的にもう発射してみたりして
だからもし北朝鮮はもうすごい貧困に陥ってる国であるならば
明らかに狂ってるでしょう
そんなこと全部やめて
国民の経済状況 一般人の経済状況を良くなるために
良くするために必死にならなくちゃいけないでしょう
世の中狂ってますよ アメリカにしたっても
ほんのちょこっとでも損するの損するんだと分かったら
もう凶暴で恐ろしくて
どんな悪いことでもしてしまっちゃう
何よりも自分たちの財産を守ることはもう正義であると
世界の正義は認めません
アメリカ Interest of the American people という The
American people でアメリカのみんなじゃないんです
一部ですね アメリカでも教育を受けられない人々って結構いるんですよ
あれほど豊かな国だと自慢するんだけど
子供たちみんな平等に教育は受けられませんよ
世界一治療を発展していると言ったっても
治療を受けることできない人っていうのはものすごいたくさんいる
で なぜかというと もう狂ってるんですよ
あんた方に治療するお金がないと
お金かかる お金持ってこいという話でしょう
お金が大事ですか？人の命が大事ですか？人が死んだって知るもんかと
それよりお金ですよという態度でしょう
だから明らかに狂ってるでしょう
で その状態はアメリカをなんとか例に出したんですけど
本当はまあ世界中どこででもあることなんですよ
政治と関係ないんですよ
共産主義であろうと 民主主義であろうが
何主義であろうが関係なく
もうまあ狂ってますよ
例えば北朝鮮はすごくまずいかもしれませんだけど
金正日さんは恐ろしい金持ちなんですよ
何百台もベンツ車持ってるという話がありましたけどね
注文するでまあ五十台ちょうだいとかね
そんな感じなんです だからこれって狂ってるでしょうに
日本の国は豊か豊かと言うんですけど
老人たちの面倒は見られませんと
なんですかね それは だったら堂々と貧困な国だと認めればいいでしょうに
貧困だったら まあおじいさんには助けてあげたいんだけど
お金がないんだよと おじいさんにご飯食べさせたいんだけど
ご飯買うお金がないんだよと言うったらば
これも普通な言い方でしょうに
戦争にはいろんなくだらんことにはすっごいもう何百億単位でもお金使ったりして
散々働かせて働かせて
国を発展された人々が弱くなったら
お前ら食いもんあげれませんよという調子に持ってくるんです
迷惑やと だから 例えば仕事をできない年取った人々は社会に対して負担だ
迷惑やという話自体も財産が大事でしょうと
大事な神様たる財産に対しては
あなた方は迷惑だという話でしょう
だから 仕事をする年の人々は財産を生んでくれるんだから
神様の奴隷として 召使いとして働いてくれるんだから
じゃあいいんじゃないかということ
だから明らかに財産が神様の位置にしているんですよ
でも 経済学者いうのは人間が管理するものであると
それどういう学問ですかね
それで仏教学学んだら仕事はないんですけど
経済学学んだらいつでも仕事があるんです
だから狂った世界ですから
それ苦しいんですよ それも苦難の原因になるんです
年を取ると同時に要求が変わるんでしょう
これ大変ですよ 若い時の要求があって
それでその採用しようとしていたんだけど
同時に年取っていくんだから要求が変わってるんですよ
新しい要求が出てくる
それのためにまた採用えなくちゃいけないんですね
得たとたん また年取ってるんだから
また要求が変わって また別なものを得なくちゃいけないんですよ
しかし 執着の上で不必要なものを捨てがたくなる
それで若い時得たものは中年になったら要りませんだけど
それからもうそれ捨てることできないんですよ
だから いらんものは私のもの
私のものよと持っていると
それ管理しなくちゃいけないんです
守らなくちゃいけないんです
しかし 自分には関係ないんです
いらないものです すごい苦しいんですよ
自分が使っているカバンだったら
維持管理するのは 守るのはいとも簡単ですよ
もう毛皮のコートはもう着る年が飛んでしまっても
いっぱいもう何 1,000万円のものを持ってる
それは維持管理しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
捨てちゃえばいいんだけど
そんな高いお金で買ったものは
それを捨てるわけにはいきませんと
いうことになるんです
時々若い時金があって豪邸作る人々いるでしょ
それで子供たちはあちこち出て行ったりして
老夫婦だけ家にでっかい家で
一部屋で十分ですけど
そこでパーティーをやる
ディナーパーティーをやる
晩餐会をやる やるために大きなホールなんかあったりして
もう本当はそんなあったってもう食べられないし
何かちょこちょこっとインスタントのを食べて生活する羽目になる
それでまた人を雇わなくちゃいけないんですね
家の管理のために 自分の家なんですけども
そうやって雇った人々は使ってる羽目になるんですよ
その人たちはすごい気楽に豪華な家を作って
その上給料まで給料までもらっちゃうんです
時々その雇う雇われている人々に支配管理される場合もあります
主人が  それは執着の問題でも
入れなくなると捨てるなく捨てた方がいいのに
それもしない 捨てた方が自分のものじゃないんだから
今の要求に苦労すればいいでしょうに
だから執着だから余計にものすごい問題が起きたりする
それも苦難の原因になる
自分には必要が必要があってもなくても
それにかかわらず得たものは変化する
自分から離れる 他人に取られることは必ずあります
自分にはいっぱい財があります
必要なものもあって必要でないものもあるんだけど
そういうものも変化するでしょ
すごい高価な馬がサラブレッドの馬がいると言っても
年々年取るでしょうに
何 1,000万円だって言っても
5  6年でもう 100万円になります
それから誰かがこれ買ってくれないのかと頼む羽目にもなります
ただであげますからと
あるいは何の事なく殺して
その肉を動物やいろんなところにまあ
あそばったりする だから結局は自分のものから逃げていくんですよ
考えてください 例えばもう
まあ馬っていうのは走れる馬ってすごい高いでしょうに
その馬を自分のもので大事に持っていると思ったら
あの値段は何年かだけでしょうに
みるみるうちに価値が減っていくでしょうに
どうしようもないんです
自分の子供ですごい愛着があっても
子供がどんどん大きくなって独立して別人になって離れていくんですね
家があっても 家がどんどんどんどん古くなっていくんですね
買った機械類は全部もう古くなってしまうんですよ
使えなくなってしまうんですね
だから必要であっても
必要でなくても 執着に関わらず
財産は変化していくんです
これがまた苦難の原因になるんです
で 結論 メリットとデメリット両方考慮すると
最終的に言えるのは財産に裏切られ
裏切られるということなんです
財産は幸福の種だぞと一方的に思うんじゃないんです
だからどちらでも じゃあ財産があれば幸福じゃないんでしょうかと
そんな変なことを仏教は言いませんよ
仏教が言うのは裏切れますよと
金があったら大変だ それは危ないということは言いません
そんなこと言わないんだけど
裏切れますよと 物事を全体的に考える理性のある人
人間なら裏切ることはない
幸福のみをもたらす 自分と不可分離で一体になる財産について学ぶ必要が生じるんです
ですから 経済学で言っている
あの本当にいい加減間違っている学問のあの人々が言うことじゃなくて
この裏切ることない財産
自分から逃げていかない財産
自分には幸福のみをもたらしてくれる財産
他は幸福のみだけじゃなくて
すごい苦悩 苦悩を作るんだから
苦悩と一緒に来る幸福はね
幸福と言えますかね そういうわけで
我々と一体になって我々の幸福をもたらしてくれる財産を
何なのかということは学ばなくてはいけないという結論になるんです
その財産に仏教ではアリーヤダナと言うんですね
だから日本語の単語は読めないんで
そういう単語は普通はないんですからね
仏教では何でもアリーヤとアナリーヤとアリーヤに分けてみる習慣があります
仏教も何でもかんでもアナリーヤかアリーヤかと二つに分けてみるんです
アナリーヤとは非正ということで
悪になる 不幸になる 正しくない
欲的で即的である 真理になれない
嘘ということですね 望む結果は得られない
堕落する 品格はない 感情的であって理性的ではない
という意味なんです すごい難しいんです
意味は 全部意味を理解しなくちゃいけない
全部まとめてアナリーヤと言うんです
だからアナリーヤと言えば
もう大胆に悪いって意味なんです
真理ではない まあ嘘ですね
望む結果は得られません
人は堕落させる 正しくない
そういうものはアナリーヤと言うんです
だから単語だけで言えば
非と正なんですよ アリーヤっていうのはそちらの反対ですよ
アリーヤダナとは善行為になる
幸福をもたらす また正しい
俗を超える真理である
望む結果は得られる 向上させる
品格がある 感情を超える
理性的である財産です
それぐらいたくさん意味は仏教では一言葉でアリーヤダナと
正なる財産 正にならない財産
裏切ることはない財産です
獲得に精進しなくてはならない財です
こんなにいいものだったら獲得しなきゃ愚か者でしょう
希望を叶ってくれる 裏切ることもない
また正しい また品格もある
理性的である 俗レベルを超えている
いわゆる微塵も間違いはない
悪いとこはない 完全に正しい
はい これでこの基本的な知識を持って経典を学んでみましょう
で これから経典は三段階に分けて説明していきます
この受け経典を 経典はエワンメーサタンというセクションありますけど
それをカットしています
アタコーオッゴーラジャマハマトーイエナバガヴァーテーヌパサン
それは M の書き方なんですけど
ドサンガミっていうのは X ですね
X って言えば N の上の点
またニシーディっていうこちらには
愛の長いもの アタコーラジャマハマットーイェーナバガワーディーナブサンガブサンガミッターバガワンタンアビワディットーエーカマンタンニシーディ
エーカマンタンニシンノーコーウッゴーラジャマハマットーバガワンタンイータダウォージャ
まあいい加減な訳ですからね
その時ウッガという名の王の大臣が世尊がおられるところに行き
尊師に拝拝し 傍らに座りました
座ってからウッガ大臣が世尊にこのように告げました
まあ行儀作法に仏教は厳しいんだから
そういう明確に書くんです
そちらいろいろ行儀作法あるんで
で
次のセクション アッチャリヤン・バンテ・アブブタン・バンテ・ヤーワ・アッドー・チャーヤン・バンテ・ニガーロ・ローハネイヨ・ヤーワ・マハッダノ・ヤーワ・マハッブ
ーボ
意味はニガーロ・ローハナがどれほど豊かでどれほど大富豪だと思うと
尊師 これは稀です これは稀有なことですと
不思議ですよと ある人のことをこの大臣言うんです
その人の名前はニガーロ・ローハナなんです
本当はニガーロ・ローハネイヨと言うんですけど
ローハネイヨと書きますけど
あの ローハネイヨ こちらにありますね
まあローハナでもいいんですけど
あの ちょっと変えたら
これはローヒニという母の息子っていうことなんですね
だからインドではこのファミリーネームは母
母系なんです だから子供が生まれたら子供は母親の名前を取るんです
みんなそうなんです お釈迦様もそうなんです
お釈迦様の名前はシッダールタ・ゴータマでしょ
母の名前なんでゴータマは
だからパーリ語で言えばシッダット・ゴータミープットーと言わなくちゃいけないんです
ゴータミープッタ ゴータミーの息子
で これちょっと注釈を入れます
政治権力者 政治的に権力を持っていて
権力者として上意を下さるウッガを驚かせるほど財産があったようですね
このニガーロさんがすごい財産がありまして
大臣も驚きました 腰が抜けてしまったんですよ
こんな金は お釈 おそらく税金とかいろいろ取るために行ったでしょうね
行って計算してみると
あるはある あるはもう腰が抜けちゃって驚いちゃって
で お釈迦様にそれを報告するんですよ
それで私もよく説法する時に皆さんに質問してくださいと言うんですよ
皆様方 すごく身を張って
昨日聞いた格好いい質問をしようと思って
理解もしていない仏教の単語をあちこち並び替えたりして
支離滅裂な質問をするんです
それは質問じゃないんです
私はすごくすっごい機嫌斜めになってくたくた言うんです
質問とは自分持ってる疑問でしょうに
格好良いも悪いも何でもないでしょうに
だからこの人はウッガサンがね
お釈迦さんに質問したんですよ
何聞いたの？本人がミガーラさんの家に行って
王様の命令で仕事をして
採算の全部統計というんですか
何て言いますか アカウントを取って
これで驚いちゃって お釈迦様
あの人えらい金持ちですね
不思議なほど金があるんだ
それだけ言ったのは 見栄張ってないんでしょうに
お釈迦様は涅槃というものは何だ
何ぞやとかね 輪廻転生は本当にあるのかどうか
そんなくだらんことを言えてないんです
輪廻転生について本当に考えて困っている人ならそれを出すんです
でないと自分が本当に驚いたことを言ったりして
見たものを言ったりして
こういうこと言いましたけどとかね
悲しくなりましたよとかね
それで十分ですよ 真理を語るためには
正直な質問 だからこれで学んでください
このウッガサンが ウッガ大臣がえらいことを聞いてないんですよね
すぐシンプルで驚いちゃったと
あの金見たら腰が抜けちゃったよという単純なことを言うんです
もしかするとウッガサンがね
私は大臣だから どうせ一般人よりは金持ちだよと
王様の側近だよと今思っていた可能性もありますよ
それでちょっと何か自分が立場上という感じで
あの人の家にいる じゃあお前の採算どうですかね
王様に税金払わなくちゃあかんでしょうと言ったら
だからもう会計士持ってきましたよと
それでミガーラさんがどうぞ調べてくださいと言ったところで驚いてしまったんです
財を数字で知るというのと
感情的に驚くのは釈尊にとってはあまり意味のないことです
だからこの人は正直に驚いちゃったということを言ったんだから
お釈迦様にとっては驚いたっていうことはあまり意味がないんですよ
具体的に数字ならなんとか意見を述べたり
アドバイスしたりすることはできるんですね
これどういうことかというと
あの人は金持ちで驚きましたというのは
あまりにも相対的にはっきりしたことじゃないんでしょうね
だからろくなものを食べてない人は
ちょこっともうコンビニのうなぎ弁当を買って食べても驚く可能性ありますよ
なんて美味しいでしょうかと
あるいは他でなんだこんなのまずくて
もう食い物じゃないやという人もいるかもしれませんでしょ
だから驚くという言葉はちょっと当てにならない単語なんですよ
お釈迦様は数字で聞くんです
大金持ちだと興奮するより
財はどれぐらいあるのかと釈尊が聞くんです
キーワアッドーパヌッカミガーロローハネイヨ
キーワマハッダノキーワマハボーゴーとお釈迦様は逆質問するんです
ウッガよ ミガーラ・ローハネイヤがどれほど財産を持ってるのですか？どれほど収入があるのですかと
ちゃんと数字で言ってくださいと
サタンダンテーサタサハッサンナンヒランニャッスコーパナワドゥルーピャス
だから彼がおそらくメモとかなんかあったでしょうかね
現代風に言えば でっかいファイルとか
もう大臣だから持っていて
それをファイル調べてきて
ウッガさんの財産がどうよと
あ これぐらいですよと
金貨で 1,000万です
銀貨の量は話にならないんだと
ちょっと数字飛ばしてるんですね
彼のそろばんでは  [笑い]金貨でも一個あるっていうことはすごい金持ちなんですよ
当時ではそれで一生生活できますよ
一個ぐらいあれば これで一千万ですからね
現代風に言えば もう何百万
億万でしょうね だからまあお釈迦様もそれにはなるほど
あんた驚くのはなるほど気持ちわかりますよと
例えば金貨千個ぐらいありますと驚いたって言ったら
なんだこれと思っちゃいますけどね
あんた大臣でしょうと
王様の財産はもっとあるでしょうと
王様の財産も知ってる人でしょうに
大体同時に仏教のエピソードの中で
このミカーラさんっていうのはね
もうもうみんな頭がおかしくなるほど金持ちでいたっていうことは普通にまあよくある話なんです
確かに金持ちと そう話に言えば
アッ
ティコッアッティコエタンウッガダナンネタンナッティーティワダメタンチェコエタンウッガダナンサダラナンアッギナウダキーナラージューヒチョーローヒアッピエヒダーヤーデーヒ
確かにそれは財産ですと
まあそれならまあ財産ですと
財産ではないと言いません
それって何だかねとは私は言いませんよと
しかし その財産を火 水
国王 盗賊 嫌な相続人と共有するものでしょうと
いわゆる自分だけのものじゃないでしょうと
独り占めできませんよと
それから注ですね 注っていうのは私が勝手に入れるところですね
合法的に仕事をして得た収入は自分のものです
しかし 具体的に自分のものだと言えないもので
簡単になくなってしまいますよ
違法的に得た収入はまあどうせ取られますからね
合法的に得た収入はどうでしょうかね
言ってみれば合法的に得た収入だから自分のものなんですけど
よくよく考えると ちょっと自分のものだとは言いにくいんですよ
火 水などの災害に遭ったらすべて持っていかれる
まあ火は簡単に持っていくんだからね
その財産は 水も洪水で流して持っていったら終わりですからね
盗賊が強引に持っていくでしょうに
国が税金 罰金などを決めて取り上げてるでしょう
自分に迷惑ばかりをかけている嫌な親戚であっても
相続権を持って財産を使用するんですね
どうしようもないんですよ
[咳]自分に金残ってあると
あっちこっちから親戚が来て
これください あれくださいで持っていくんだ
所有権のない所有物ですね
結局は 所有物ですけど
所有権はないと 富を得るために自分一人で頑張るが
得た収入は自分だけのものではありませんね
これでおかしいでしょう
自分一人で仕事して収入得なくちゃいけないんだけど
得た途端これ自分だけのものじゃないんですね
私は金持ちだ 地主だと思っても
本当にその通りですか？なぜ他人にもクレームを言えるのですか？平気で自分の財産に他の人はクレームつけるでしょう
例えば一文もない女性でも
もう結婚して まあ五 六年もうもうろくな仕事もしないでいて
それで離婚になったところで何のことなくクレームつけるんだから
人の財産持っていくんだから
それでアメリカではそれは商売の一つでしょうね
結婚して金持ちになるという
結婚しては離婚する 結婚しては離婚する
二回ぐらい離婚したらものすごいもう金持ちです
だから自分の財産ならそうなるはずがないでしょう
まあ政府もね 随分簡単勝手に取り上げたりする
私のものと思うと 財産が自分を苦しめます
だから だから事実はそうなんですね
自分が儲かったんでしょ
正しく苦労して 汗流して
なのに自分のものじゃないんですね
それは事実ですから それ忘れちゃうと
いい これは私のものと思っちゃうと
その財が自分を楽しませるんじゃなくて苦しめます
だから必ずも財は欲求を満たしてくれるはずじゃないんです
自己さえも自分のものにならずというブッダの言葉なんです
自分自身 体さえもね 体と心さえも自分の方にならないんだよと
体 自分の言うこと聞かないでしょ
がんになるわ 年取るわ
心臓がね 弱くなるわ 血圧は高くなるわ
治療してもなかなかうまくそれに対応してくれないわ
時々薬飲んだり手術してもらったりするでしょうに
体は対応しないんですね
いい加減にしろよと 痛いでしょう
早く治るよと言うこと聞かないんですよ
では心は自分のものですかね
じゃないんです 勝手に回転するんですね
自分が思いたくないんだけど
ずっとそのものばっかり思っているんですね
それですごく精神的にも病気になったりして
これって真理ですよ 自分さえも自分のものにならないんだと
まして財産はと まあ書いてないところは
まして財産はということなんです
言わんやかななんでしょうかね
はい それで経典の最初のセクションはそれで終わるんですね
すごい心配ですよ ウッガさんが驚きました
お釈迦様は あのね どれぐらいお金があるのかと
これぐらいですよと 金貨で千万
千万 千万ですよ ああ それだったらまあ結構財産ですけど
驚きますよと 驚くのも腰が抜けるのは無理がない
しかしね あれはあいつのものじゃないんだよと
あれは水と火と王様と盗賊と嫌な親戚
親戚と共有しなくちゃいけないんだよ
それでセクションの一終わり
間違いなく正しく自分のものだと言える財産
他人に支配する権利がない真の財産ということをブッダが教えてあげるんです
だから あの大臣のあの素朴な質問でお釈迦様はどうして真理を語る機会を得たんです
自分のものになる財財っていうのは七つですね Satta
kho imāni ugghadanāni asādhāranāni aggina udakena rājuhe
crorehe appi dāyādehi
katamāni satta.ひみず国王盗賊嫌な相続人たちに共有することはできない
財は七つです いわゆる自分だけのもの七つです
七宝の話ですね この七つは何でしょうか saddhā
dhanaṃ sīla dhanaṃ hiri dhanaṃ ottappa dhanaṃ sutta dhanaṃ
cāga dhanaṃ paññā
dhanaṃ.imāni kho uggha satta dhanāni asādhāranāni aggina
udakena rājuhe crorehi
appi dāyādehi.それは一
信 二 道徳 三は読めない
四も読めない  三と喜  三と喜ですね
で 五は学ぶことですね
六は施しで 七は智慧なんです
それでブッダだからこそ
こうやって数字でまとめて言うことはできますよ
これってすごい智慧なんですよ
もし誰かがいい八番目もないのと八番目はこれではないかと言っちゃうと
ブッダに立場がないんでしょう
だからその自由を与えているんです
もしあなた方に八番言えるならば言ってみなさいよと
人間には言えないです
どんな天才であっても
なぜならばお釈迦様はもう賢者なんですね
悟ってるんですよ 自分が完全に悟っているということは
いつでも証明として出しながら語っているんです
だから七つですよというのは大変なことなんです
それで一つ一つ説明していきます
一 saddhā信 あるいは確信ということなんですね
物事に対して自信がなく
曖昧でいることは危険ですよ
大体みんなね 人間っていうのはそういうことでしょう
曖昧でしょう 仕事をしても自信がない
もういろいろ仕事を皆様やってる仕事に自信があるのかというと
もう全然自信がない 時々お医者さんが言うんですよ
できれば他の仕事をやりたいんだよと
学校の先生たちは結構いるんですね
できれば別の仕事をやりたい
だから自信がない生き方っていうのは
不思議ですよ 我々の生き方が確信を持てる
えーと 論理的な具体的なものでなくてはならないんですね
だから自分の人生にぐらいは確信を持った方がいいんですよ
論理的で具体的でしっかりと生きることは
これが宝物なんですよ
それで裏切れる？裏切れませんよ
しかし 俗世間ではすべてのものに対して確信は持てない
それから世界は事実を語らない
じゃあ俗世間で全部知っておこうと思っても
誰も本当のことを言わないんですよ
金明正さんに聞いたっても
日本の総理誰でしたっけ？安倍さんに聞いたっても
二人とも堂々と嘘を言うんですね
ブッシュさんに聞いたっても明らかに嘘を言ってるんだから
だからどうすればいいんですかね
世界は事実を語らないんですよ
会社もそうでしょう 三菱でなんかね
欠陥部品があって 事故を起こしてずっと隠して騙していたでしょうに
大型ね トラックなんかバスなんかのね
ハブがもうすごい設計上問題がありまして
これ外れちゃって もう車輪が飛んでしまったりして人も死んだでしょうね
それでもそれは管理の問題であると人のせいにしてしまって
そういうことっていうのはもう毎日のことなんです
本当は毎日朝新聞を開けて嘘ばっかり読んでるんですよ
あれ 2週間経ったら あれ
別のこと言ってるんだから
まあ今日私には個人的には嘘の程度知るニュース一つありましたけど
自分のところにテロたちがいて
もう大体10歳  8歳 もう12歳の子供たちを誘拐して軍隊に入れるんですね
この自爆テロいろいろやるために
これずっとそれやっていたんです
それにもう言って言っても言っても言ってももう聞かない
それでもはっきりと証拠がある
いくらでも まあそれでヨーロッパ人がテロを応援してるんですけど
いくら何でもここまで情報あると
もう無視するわけにもいきません
だからそれだけはやめてくださいというふうに言われたりして
でもやっていて で 今度は自分たちが上を取るために新聞広告出てますよ
あの8人ぐらい子供たちを自分たちが年をごまかして入隊したんだから
あの教育センターに送りましたと
それこれ一個のニュースでおそらくヨーロッパの方が舞い上がると思いますけどね
本人は知ってます それは嘘ですよと
しかし この仏教徒を殺すためには
まあそれぐらいで十分やってることで取ると思いますけど
だからあれは明らかに嘘だと思いますよ
あるいは誘拐した子供たちはあんまりにも体が弱くて
向こうの人間には年ごまかすことできないんですよね
体が小型でしょ みんな
だからもうスリランカ人で18歳の二十歳の人やと言ったっても
日本人は年を聞かないで顔を見ると
こいつは14歳じゃないのと思うぐらい小さいんですよ
だから年をごまかすっていうのは
これはアメリカの子供たちにはできますよ
日本の子供たちにもできます
もう体ができてますからね
成長してますから でも
あの あの国の子どもたちにはもうできん
またずっとテロのところで生活してるんだから
ろくに食べ物はないわ
教育はないわ もうものすごい苦労してるんだから
南の子供たちよりはもうなおさら成長が悪いと思います
しかし それはどこでもいいんですけど
ああいう風に もうどーんと国際的にあらゆるマスコミで流しちゃえば
あ あのグループはまとめになってるんだとかね
だから鎮静しなくちゃいけないんだという話は言えますよ
だから嘘ってのは そういう風に微妙にちょこっと
アメリカはイラクに爆弾を落とした理由はもう
もう何て言いますか テロを根絶するためにと
聞きたいのはイラクはどこでテロ活動したんでしょうかと
どこでもやったという証拠は一個もなかったんです
イラク人は色々あるかもしれませんだけど
かなり歴史のあるもう人物でしょうし
結構態度高くてしっかりしてますよ
個人的にちょこちょこと友達になってみると
かなり立派な人間ではないかと思うぐらい
もうすごいしっかりしていますよ
戦争の時はアメリカの報道よりはあのフセンさんの何とか大臣がいて
毎日テレビで喋っていた人がいたでしょ
あの人一番人気あるんですね
もうむちゃむちゃ負けてるのに
むちゃくちゃもう我々は必ず勝ちますよとかね
かわいくても言ってることは
あの やっぱりその人的人格なんですよ
すごいおおらかでおおらかでいるんだからね
あれかなり当時人気あったんです
私もそのニュース見るたびに
そいつの顔を見たくて
今日は何言うのでしょうかと
だからそういう証拠は何もないのに
まあそういうことで言ったら
国民から一般の意見聞いたら
もう六十 七十パーセントぐらい
やっぱりイラクはテロをやっているんだと思っているんですね
だから証拠なくても それって嘘を流すことで意見変えることはできますから
我々は毎日新聞見て テレビ見て
何聞いてるのかというと
明らかに真っ赤な嘘ばっかり言ってるんですよ
確かにニュース関係は裏付けは調べますよ
あなた本当に言ったんでしょうか
はい 言いましたと で 裏付け取れたと
でも言ったことが嘘だったらどうしますかね
どうしようもないですよ
そこで毎日同じニュースを追っていくと
それはどのように変わっていくのかと見えますよ
我々あんまり鋭くないんだから忘れているんですね
昨日のことは なら あんた昨日言ったことと今日言ってること違うんじゃないのかと
そうは思わないんですね
そういうことで世界は事実を語らないということは言えます
だから我々には あの事実知って確信持ちましょうと言っても結構難しい
ですからどうするのかと
罪に悪にならないように気を付ければ十分です
世の中の人は何言ったっても
それにもうもうもう構うことなく
自分の生き方は罪にならないように
悪にならないようにと
そのポイントでしっかりするんです
人に頼まれても 人に脅されても
罪になることはやりません
それは私の生き方ですよ
これぐらいで真確信というものは確立します
やってみるとすごいシンプルなんです
悪いことならしませんと
その場でその場で判断していけばいいでしょうに
[背景音楽]それで ものすごく自分が頑丈で
もう悪いことはしないよって決めちゃうと
他の人はあんまり言うことをしません
怖くなるんです 会社でも部下に
あの人にはこれは頼まなきゃいいんだよと
あの人はやらないんだ
しかし 別な正しい仕事を頼んだらしっかりやってくれるんだから
その人にはそういったことを頼んで
まあアコライトには悪いことを頼みましょうということになるので
だから自分の身を守られます
信仰ということをね フェース
ビリーフと英語で言うことは仏教は認めない
確信がないから信仰する
信じるんでしょ？確信があったら証拠あるんだから
別に信仰します 信仰しますって言わなくてもね
信じるものはもう是か非かは五分五分ですね
例えば神様が信じると言ったら
いるかもしれません いないかもしれませんでしょ
だから五分五分なんですね
この曖昧はダメです 認めない
仏教は五分五分だったら曖昧だよと
論理的に納得いけることは仏教的な信仰です
仏教で信仰っていうのは論理的に納得いける
ということです 例えばブッダの話を勉強してよくわかりましたと言ったならば
それは信仰が出たということなんです
別にわかったという意味じゃないんです
わかるということは 論理的に考えて
具体的に考えてわかりましたということでしょ
わかったと言えないよ
もう論理的に納得いかなかったら
信じられること 納得いけることは真理の証拠にはなりません
わかったんだからといって納得いったんだから
だから事実とは言えません
ただ 可能性は高い よくよく
例えばよく私に聞く質問で
この輪廻はあるのかと
私は信じませんよと 私は論理的にこれだからこうでしょう
原因には結果あるでしょうしと
原因があったら結果が出さないでなくなるわけがないでしょうと
ですから人は死ぬっていうことは原因だったらなんで結果ないのかとかね
物事は何も停止しないで動いているでしょうにと
なのにあなたは何で死で全部停止すると思っているんでしょうかと
そうすると相手は反論できなくて
なるほどよくわかりましたということは
なんとなく輪廻も論理的には可能性ある
成り立つんだよとわかったわけじゃないんです
だからそれが輪廻の証拠というわけでもないんです
いわゆる輪廻が正しいということの可能性が高くなるだけ
だから信仰は信仰する故に正しいということではなくて
正しい信仰なら可能性
真理になる可能性がかなり高いということなんです
ちょっと難しいんだけど
忘れてもいいんです そのポイントは
証拠のない信仰はアモーリカーサッダーです
証拠のない信仰には いわゆる根拠のない信仰にはアモーリカーサッダーと呼ぶんです
だから神を信じることは完全にアモーリカーサッダーなんです
因縁に基づいて具体的にデータを調べて結論に達する信はアーカーラーティーサッダーです
理性に基づく信仰というんです
だから これだからこうなるんだ
あれだからこうなるんだ
これだからこうなるんだとかね
考えて考えて だからこういうことじゃないのと
だって世の中で嘘をついてひどい目に遭った人々のケースを次から次へと調べて調べて
嘘のおかげでどれほど我々苦しんでいるのかと
裁判もむちゃくちゃ時間かかるでしょうに
嘘を言うんだからでしょ
だから誰一人も信頼できなくて
不安でものすごく苦しんでますよ
子供が言うことも信頼できないし
旦那が言うことも信頼できないし
奥さんが言うことも信頼できないし
だからなんかすごく苦しいんですよ
それである人はやっぱり嘘っていうのは良くないと思いますよと
決めたらそれが信仰なんですよ
正しい信仰 なぜならばデータは証拠になるんです
しかし お釈迦様が嘘を損なかれという言葉とは違います
お釈迦様はこれをもう発見して正しいと全部もう知った上で言うんだから
我々も同じこと言うんだけど
我々は信仰で言うんです
で 殺してはならないと我々も言ってるでしょうに
お釈迦様も言ってるでしょうに
我々は殺してはならないというのは
我々の見た情報 色んなことを見て
殺人は良くないんだよと
正しくないんだよと しかし
なぜ正しくないのかと
で 聞いちゃうと これがちょっとわからないんですね
だって悪いでしょうということで終わっちゃうんですね
だからそちらにあるのは真なんですね
お釈迦様に聞くと お釈迦様はこの心の法則まで知り尽くしてるんだから
殺しを行う場合は 心はこういう風に働くんだよと
それで確実にこういう結果になるんだよと
ということだから お釈迦様は人を殺すなかれということはもう真理です
我々は人を殺してはいけませんということは信仰です
しかし 真理に近いんでしょ？正しくなる可能性は高いんですよ
お釈迦様に対して見れば
お釈迦様は同じこと言ってるんだから
それで私たちもさらに研究して
自分で経験したところでも
ぴったし同じ結果に出ますよ
だからアーカロディサッダという信仰は真理に近い
可能性は高いということになるんです
真は自信に 自信につながり
喜びを与えたり 失敗を覚めさせたりするんですよ
自信 確信があると仕事はもうしっかりできますよ
それで確信があって仕事をすると
疲れなくて その代わりもう楽しいんですよ
喜びですよ まあこれは私にできる仕事やと
私はこんな仕事は失敗しませんよと
これ確信ですよ だから確信があって生きてみると
もうすっごいもう楽しくて
それから失敗もしないし
信がある人に嫌気はないんですね
はぁ やっと終わったとかね
なんで私にこんなやりにくい仕事をもうま
まいてくるのかとかね
回ってくるのかとか これ自信がない時なんですね
ですから この信というのは人間の本当の財産なんですよ
それがあると 俗世 俗世間の財産なんか問題にならない
失敗もしないし 仕事もできるし
だからその人は私はこれぐらい金儲けなくちゃとかね
これぐらい昇格しなくちゃとか
そんなのはどうでもいい
もう自動的に成功していくんです
だから 自分の心の状況だからね
この確信するっていうこと
それがまああった方がいいっていうことになります
2番目 シーラダナンという言葉で
あの えんの 縁を忘れてください
同義語  [笑い]非道徳的な人の財産はなくなる
知識があっても雇う人はいません
道徳ない人 いわゆる犯罪者ですね
我々雇いますかね すごい知識人だからと
立派なエンジニアだからといって犯罪者は雇わないでしょう
だから道徳が一番大事なんですよ
あれこれと学歴持っていても
学歴は物語ってくれませんよ
この人を雇うべきやということに
もうカニングして合格した可能性もあるしね
裏金を払って合格した可能性もあるし
知識は危険なことに使用する
それは非道徳 犯罪者が知識を危険なことに使用するんですよ
人類にも自分にも危険を招くんですよ
例えば素晴らしい科学者でしょ
原子爆弾を作るのは 普通の高校の先生たちじゃないでしょ
世界中をこの悪い国ぶりにイランやらリビアやら北朝鮮に原子爆弾の技術を教えたのはパキスタン人でしょう
すごい立派な知識人なんですよ
政府の許可でむちゃくちゃその設計図やら組み立て方やら何でもかんでも売ったりして金儲かっちゃって
それでアメリカは仲良くなってくるところで
これバレて大変なことで
それでもその人を処分することはやめちゃって
逆にその人だけ悪いということにして
今の大統領が自分の身を守ってもらったんで
全部嘘ばっかり固まってるんです
今北朝鮮にグスグス言ってますけど
技術を与えた人には何一つ言えません
売って金儲けた人に その人
多分その人は大統領まで引っ張ることを言ってる
脅してるんです 冗談じゃないんだよと
証拠を持ってますよと
だからそれをはい なかったことにしましょうと
あれほどうるさいアメリカもはい
わかりました なかったことにしましょう
そういう世界ですよ とにかく人類に迷惑をかけるのは道徳のない知識人なんですよ
だから道徳のない桁違い
天才的な知識人があるということは不幸なんです
そのようには頭の悪い道徳ある人々は世界に平和と幸福をもたらすんですよ
道徳は破らない人間ですよ
本当の財産は そういう人々だと財産がどんどん増えていくんです
だから本当の財産は道徳なんです
忘れているんです みんな
世界は道徳を重んじる人に責任を任す
得た財産は逃げない 道徳ある人の
落ち着いて穏やかに生きられる
自分が悪いこと何もしていないんだったら穏やかにいられます
道徳は決して人を裏切ることはしません
なんでこんな円滑なんです
慚という言葉ね 慚とは恥じることです
ただの恥ずかしがり屋とは正反対です
悪 非道徳 罪を恥じるんです
恥ずかしがるのではなく
心が強く曖昧なく生きるんです
この恥という意味なんですけど
非っていうのは しかし
恥ずかしがり屋で表に出ないで隠れているという意味じゃないんです
悪を恥じるんですよ 悪いことはもう恥ずかしい
やるもんかと かなり態度でかいんですよ
この態度でかいことは
仏教では恥という単語で素晴らしい財産だと言っています
だから心が弱いんだったらできない
良い意味のプライドです
すごくプライドあります
何にせよ悪いことだけはしません
気持ち悪いと やるもんかと
品のない人でしょ そんなことやるの
という恥ずかしさなんです
そんなことやったら恥ずかしくて死んじゃいますよと
という気分で生活することなんです
だから悪を恥じることが本当の採算なんです
だから自分からは間違ってでも失敗は起こりませんね
信頼できますよ 会社に入ったら
新入社員であっても もうすぐすぐ昇格させちゃって責任を任すということはいくらでもできます
あの人はもう悪いことを恥じるんだからね
かなりプライド高いんだから
あの人に頼みましょうよと
あの人を昇格させましょうよということになります
で オッタッピヤ そちらはかなり売れないみたいですね
キですね キとは怖いという意味ではありません
本当は 辞書を引いたら怖いということなんですけど
これは怖い怖いという意味じゃないんです
怖がり屋でもありません
罪 悪を 悪 非道徳 行為を怖がるんです
悪いことを怖がるんです
こんなこと怖いでしょうと
逮捕されたらもうとんでもない
怖いでしょうと 暖房もない部屋でいなくちゃあかんでしょうと
そういう風にもの怖がるんですね
悪いこと 恐れを感じて
注意深く謙虚で生きるんですよ
だからそれは採算の道なんですね
罪非難を恐れて 精神的安全
安穏を重んじてしっかり生きることできます
生きることです だからキということある人は
精神的に安定して安穏でしっかりと生きているんです
危険なことは絶対しない
危険なこと言ったって危険なことやりますよ
罪になることはしません
まあ例えば じゃあ新しい仕事にでも挑戦してみようかなとかね
これはうまくいくかいかないかわからないんですけど
ある程度危険でしょうね
そういうものはやりますけど
新しい仕事に挑戦したんだからって
それは悪いことじゃないでしょうに
だから悪いことだけはしない
ということはあると 仕事を通して新しい仕事に
危険なことに挑戦したとしても
うまくいくんです 失敗はしない
これ 4番目ですね で  5番目スッタ
学ぶこと 昔は知識を得るために師匠から聞かなくてはならなかったんですね
本の文化はなかったんだからね
バフッスッタというのは多聞者という意味なんですね
たくさん聞いたことがある人
知識人という意味になるんですね
だからパーリ語でサンスクリット語で辞書を引いてるバフッスッタって言えば
もうたくさん聞いてるとなんとか書いてるかもしれませんだけど
意味は知識人 学者ということなんです
俗世間では学ぶものは限りなくあるが
人の寿命は短いでしょ
したがって役に立つものを選んで学ぶのです
それで学ぶと言ったっても
どこまで学べばいいんですかね
いくらでもあるでしょう
でも我々の寿命は短いでしょうに
何でも学ぶことできないんですよ
医学学ぶにしたってこれ一生かかっちゃうんですよ
医学も学んで 同時にもう一流の音楽家にもなれそうと思ったら
これは成り立たないんです
時間ないんです そこで論理的に具体的に考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから学ぶものたくさんあるんだけど
一つ役に立つものを自分で選ぶんです
これなら私に役に立ちますよと
あまり自分に適した職業
学問とか選ばなくてもいいんですよ
あれって弱い人のね 腰抜けの考え方なんですね
適した学問とかね 合ってる学問とかね
ないわけがないんだけど
学べば何でもできますよ
ちょっと慣れにくいことでも学んでみれば
まあ何のこともないんです
だから別に頭に制限する必要ないんでしょ
それぞれ人の人格を見て
ああ この子供にはこの学問が適している
この子供にはこの学問が適していると決めちゃうと
これは知識にリミットをつけたことなんですね
だから本人が自分に役に立つものを選んで役に立つんだから,もう歯を噛んでやればいいんです
だから知識はそれで増えます
しかし 道徳は必須科目です
必須科目です これ 誰でも人間なら学ばなくてはいけないんです
他何も学ばないで道徳だけ学んだっても学者なんです
幸福にはなります だから世間で言うことと違って
仏教は道徳を学ぶことは必須科目で
その上プラスアルファで自分の役に立つことを学んでください
まあ道徳だけ知っても料理ぐらいも作れないんだったらね
まあまあかえって迷惑でしょうしね
だから役に立つことは知った方がいいんです
世界史は必修科目にしなくてもいい
ん？ 世界史は必修科目にしなくてもいいんです
まあそれはいりませんけどね
まあそれ本当は学生先生たちよく考えて
子供たちにもどうせ将来的に役に立ったものを教えていればね
もうそれ人権侵害 法律破ったと思いますよ
だって日本史勉強だって嘘ばっかしでしょ
教えているの かえって知っておくと
中国人に韓国人に怒られるだけでしょう
あの昨日かな このシンガポールの前の総理大臣がね
大学で講演してね まあこの戦争についてね
私は日本人ならね すみませんでしたと
我々やったことはもうとっても間違ってましたと
一言で言ってものを終わりますよと
でも私は日本人じゃないんだからねというんですよ
すごいいい表現使って言っちゃったんですね
これはもう遅いんだと
いうことで まあそんなのはもう気にしないことにしましょうと
向こうが落ちつくんです
格好悪いでしょう 日本にしてみれば
占領されてくったくってやられた側は
まああんなことは気にしないことにします
こっちは人格者で こっちは未だにだらしないということ
だから本当は日本史を教えない方がいいと思いますよ
何学んだっても世界平和につなげなければ意味がないでしょうに
我々の子供たちはどんな国に行ったっても
みんなに愛されちゃって
すごく幸せでいることできなかったら
なんでそれ教えるんですかね？子供憎んでるんですかね
だから私は個人的な主観なんですけど
教えなくたっても何の損もないんだよと知ってますけど
しかし 教えるべきなのは道徳なんですよ
道徳がなかったら日本でもいられませんし
外国でもいられませんし
会社も雇いませんし 自分でもごまかしばっかしの人生になっちゃうし
嘘に固まって生きることになるでしょうし
これでは財産は入ってこないんです
理性を育てるために 物事に判断ができるようになるために
真理を発見するために
最初に学ぶことは必要です
どう見たっても学ぶことは必要なんです
で 仏教はキリスト教やらそういう神を信じる宗教と違いますから
やっぱり頭が良ければ良いほどありがたいんですよ
すごく論理的で もうビシビシ何でも調べてから信じる人間だったら
それがありがたいんです
どうか助けてください
救いたまえ 助けたまえとかいう人間っていうのは人間らしからんと
何かあったら神に祈る
自分で頑張らない とんでもないと
だから仏教はすごくこの学問を応援するんですが
世の中の学校教育は全部キリスト教に握られてますけど
占領されてますけど 大富豪の家の生まれでも
無知な人にはその財産を楽しめないでしょう
すごい財産があるところで
ものすごい無知な人が生まれたらね
財産全部なくなるんです
貧乏で生まれても知識さえあれば豊かになるんです
だから金は外のものだからね
生まれたら誰でも裸で生まれるでしょうに
何も持って生まれるわけないでしょうに
その人が裸の人を知識だけ
必要な知識だけ 役に立つ知識だけ畳んでおけば
もう財産はもう磁石みたいな感じで自分に引かれたまんまでいるんです
6番目 チャーレ 施しですね
人は得することばかり考える
あれ欲しい これ欲しいと考えて行動するが
実際はそううまくはいきません
何でしたっけ？利を得る
秘密 秘密は  秘密は施しにあるんです
これすごい明確な秘密いや
ないんです 法則なんですよ
あれ欲しい これ欲しいって
この法則に逆らってるんですよ
欲しい欲しいと思うと
そのものは逃げるんですよ
まあこれわかりやすく言えば
もう野生の動物を捕りたくて
あっち隠れてこっち隠れて追って追って罠を仕掛けたり
いろんなことをやっちゃうと
動物たちはとことん逃げる
逃げるだけ で 捕まってもむちゃくちゃ攻撃する
あまりにも攻撃のあまりの強さに
動物が死ぬか自分が死ぬかどちらかになっちゃって
もう全然結果ダメなんです
では 餌撒いておけばどうですか？と
勝手に来るんです 攻撃もしない
それで餌をまくことで
丁寧に論理的に具体的に考えて
ちゃんと時間で決まってる時間で餌を置いてて
そこでちょこちょこと自分がいることをなんとなく認識させて
それでも逃げていったりして
動物は逃げますけどね
それでも餌があったりして
次の日も餌あげたらやっぱり人の気配感じたりして
それでどんどん まあもうこんな感じだってもう危険がないんだから
動物はね それで もうそれからちょこちょこと体見せたりとか
やがて来る時は手で餌あげることできるようになってくるんですよ
だからそれほど難しいということでもないんですよ
パンダというのは人間にはなかなか馴染めないという話があるんですけど
野生のパンダ than 15人が面倒見ている学者の人々とずいぶん仲良しなんです
野生なんですけども 来たら何のことなくそばに見てるし
もう気にしなし来たって
だから普通は凶暴でもうなかなか馴染めない動物なんですね
しかし 施しということでしょ
パンダの面倒見てあげて
面倒見てあげて それで動物たちは
この人はいっぱい親切にしてくれるんだということで
適切に反応するだけ そういうことで
この そういう単純な理由でもわかるんでしょうね
例えば何か取ろうとすると
そのものが逆にエネルギーとして逆に働くんです
与える人にのみ得を まあ得る権利が生じるんです
与える人に得る権利が生じる
例えばカラスにでもずっと餌付けしちゃうと
カラスと遊ぶことは その餌をあげる人にだけ権利が生じているんです
その人の肩に乗ったりするわ
頭の上に乗ったりするわ
もう遊んでくれる 他の人が来ると逃げる
あんたカラスにこせえ人間とその人と遊んでるんだから
私とも一緒に遊んでくれって言っても
それはやってくれない
だから与える人に権利があるんです
得る権利が 金儲けに仕事をする人は疲れるんです
仕事の目的は金儲けやと思っちゃうとかなり疲れます
自分が他人に何を貢献しているのか
それがポイントなんです
仕事は金儲けじゃなくて
社会に私はこれこれぐらいは貢献してしますとかね
この貢献することが大事にするんです
そうなってくると自分が貢献しているだけだから
自分に収入得る権利が自動的に成り立ってるんです
だから収入は勝手に来るんです
収入を追って頑張らなくてもいい
収入を追っちゃうと収入に逃げられるんです
これって仕事上大事なことなんですよ
仕事っていうのは 何かを人類に
人間に 誰かに貢献することなんです
今の現代世界ではほとんど何にも貢献にならないのに
その人々に限って大金取ってるんですね
それ狂ってるんだからしょうがないんだけど
ただ仕事っていうのは
自分が何か貢献して 貢献することだけに集中して
本当に役に立つように計らって計らってやるんです
そうすると 自分の財布を見なくても
財布にちゃんと入ってるはずなんです
まあ例えばあんまりケチで
もう先の気持ちもある人が品物を買って
もうできればお金払いたくないという気持ちあっても
自分が買った品物は本当に役に立っていて
これすごい満足だと いいものだと言っちゃうと
お金はそれで お金は払いませんって気分にはなりませんよ
やっぱりお金払わなくちゃってことになるんです
買ったものを取ったことはないし
もうただ面白いんだから注文してみただけで
まあいいやとごまかしちゃうんで
それでお金払わないで
ですから この仕事の世界では
この大事なポイントは貢献という言葉にあるんです
例えば自分が数学の先生ですと
それで老人ホームのおばさんたちに数学を教えるんだそうです
だって誰も雇いませんよ
金もくれません 役に立ってないんだから
では犬に何とかできるかなんか数学を教えろと言っても
誰もそんなのもう金になりません
じゃあ子供たちに数学を教えるというと
これは子供たち役に立ってるでしょうに
日本に何か貢献している
そうするとお金は返ってきます
だから純粋に数学を教えることは仕事であるということは成り立たないんです
数学は役に立つところに教えてあげると仕事なんです
ですから まあ仕事っていうのはいくらでもあります
人間というのはいろんなものを必要としていますよ
ちょっと理性があれば
世の中を見ると この人にこれがいいし
この人のあれが必要とかあるでしょうに
それは何か貢献していくと
それが仕事になっちゃうんです
収入は勝手に来る 勝手に来て付いちゃったもんだからね
別に だからもっと面白いたとえで言えば
貢献することで自分がなんかすごい磁石になっちゃうんですね
あげればあげるほどなんか磁石的なエネルギーを持って
その磁石ですから もう財産というものはもうどんどんどんどん
もう勝手に来て付いちゃって
もう捨てても捨ててもまたついてくるという
まあ嫌ですよと 例えば自分が人間で磁石になったらどうなる？金属ものあったら全部もうつくでしょうね
つかないように置いといて
重りをしておかないと
ダメでしょう ですから
財産 そういうものになったらどうですかね
気持ち悪い？で 豊かない人がよく言うでしょ
もう金っていうのは儲かるもんじゃないんだ
向こう側から来るんだよと
やっぱりそういう人々は過去世でいっぱい布施をしたりしたんだから
今世で全然もう金もうかる気持ちもないんだけど
金だけ勝手に入ってくるわけ
困ったもんだと これ 困ったもんだと言ったって入ってくる
それで欲しい欲しいと泣いてる人たちが全然入ってこないんです
金がないことで本当に困っているのに
それは過去生でも施したことはないんです
だから磁石がないんです
欲しい欲しいと思っちゃうと
逆の磁石のあれ 何でしたっけ
あれ変わっちゃうんですね
あの 何て言いますか あれを
プラスマイナスが  極？極が変わっちゃうんですね
というと引っ張っ ても引き離せなくなっちゃうんです
それで強引に引っ張っても苦労して捕まっておかないと
ちょっと手が緩むから落ちてる
普通みんなの財産はそういうものでしょうに
だから施しの法則で財産になるんです
だから金持ちじゃったらダメですよと
施し 貢献 何かしてあげることにしなさいよ
人に貢献する人は他人に守られる
えっと 財は外のものです
貢献した人は世界の財の一部を使用する権利を得ているのです
施しをする人は他人に愛される
敵がなくなる 守られる
心が綺麗になる エゴがなくなるんですね
いいことたくさんあります
それで 7番目 最後パンニャー
知識 これは知識と違います
パンニャー 知恵というのは
知識とは世間のことを学ぶことです
世間のことを学ぶ それは知識というんですね
生きるために役に立つ道具です
知識はただの道具なんです
生きるために役に立つ道具
普遍性に問題がある 知識にはちょっと問題があるんですよ
普遍性 ある人にある場所で
ある時間で役に立つ知識は
別な人に別な場所で別な時間で役に立たない
知らぬ間になることはよくあります
知識は普遍的で どこででも役に立つということはないんです
例えば英語の達人が英語だから知る
他何も知識はない 英語文学でノーベル賞を取っているとしましょう
それで無人島に流れてしまったとする
じゃあノーベル賞を取っているんだから
ちゃんと食っていられるでしょうね
役に立ちませんね 場所が変わっちゃうと
それでヨーロッパに行ったところでもうちょっと文章を書いただけで大金が入ってくる
だから知識には普遍性では問題があるんですよ
例えば英語はもう世界中どこでも使用できる素晴らしい知識だよと
もし何か起きて 例えば中国がすごい立派な国になってしまって
で 地球上でたくさん人間喋る言語は中国語でしょう
みんなやっぱり中国語を学びましょうということになっちゃうと
英語はどうでもいいことになってしまいますね
昔は英語よりもフランス語が人気だったでしょ
英語を喋る人々でもフランス語わからなかったら困ったもんだと
知識人ではありませんと言っていた時期はありましたよ
しかし今はね それほど立場がないんです
そういうことでもう普遍性には問題あるんです
だから学問 科学であろうが医学であろうか
他の文学であろうが 学問というものは普遍的に役に立つってことじゃないんです
ある場所である時間で役に立つだけ
それはよく覚えておいた方がいいんです
だから我々はどんな知識を学ぶかっていうことを
この時空関係で決めた方がいいんです
50年前に英語を学んで随分もう立派になった自信があります
今も覚えているんだよと言ったっても
その英語は古いんです
今使えないんです というわけで
まあ時空関係っていうのは大事なんです
どんな学問でも 科学はすごいことを発見しているんだ
それじゃ役に立ちませんよ
例えば原子爆弾いろいろ事故を起こしちゃって
人類の文明がなくなったら
あの科学は何の役にも立ちませんでしょうに
それでも地球の周りでいっぱい衛星が回っているかもしれませんだけど
誰もあることも知らなくなっちゃうしね
知恵は真理を知ることです
知恵っていうのは真理
事実 物事の真理を知ることなんです
それはもう時空とは関係ないんです
だから知恵と知識はかなり違うということを覚えておいてください
知恵は属定的です 間違えた
知識は属定的です 知恵は属的なものじゃないんです
真理知ってることなんです
本当のことを知ることなんです
真理は普遍的です 変わらないと言えるものです
生きるという問題を最終的に解決します
智慧が生きるという問題は最終的に解決します
智慧は向上してゆく 生命は到達する頂点です
生命は向上する しなくてはいけない
我々は向上して 向上して
向上して どこに行くのかというと
智慧という頂点に達するんです
そこで以上向上はないんです
最高な宝物です しかし
残念なことに真理を語ったのは釈尊だけです
これはもうどうしようもない
真理知りたければ 智慧が欲しければ
ブッダの教え学ぶしかもう方法はないんです
それはもう残念なことに断言的に言えます
なぜ残念かというと 世の中の人
他の人はもういたって悪くないでしょうに
誰も発見しなかったんだからね
で セクション３に入ります
結論のところに 裏切れない自分と一体になる本当の財を獲得するために挑戦するということで
勝利者 ヤッサエーテーダナアティイッティアプリサッサワスウェーマハッダノ
ちょっと間違いです こちらホーティアジャイヨーデーヴァマヌッセ
男であろう 女であろう
この才があるならば その人こそが大富豪と言えるのです
その人は人間界でも天界でも勝利者というのです
この七つの宝物があれば
この世でももう勝利者なんですよ
天国に至っても勝利者なんです
まあ勝利者といっても
もうこちらが言ったら負けないものという
誰にも負かすことできないと
いわゆるもう最高の勝利者である
ヤッセーテーダナ まだ同じことになっちゃってる
何でしょうかね なんかコンピューターなんか問題起こしちゃったんです
なんか全然日本語打てなくなっちゃって
この辺になってくると
むちゃもういくら頑張っても日本語が全く出なくなっちゃって
これでまた時間なくなっちゃったんです
タスマサッダンジャシーランジャパサダムダンマダッサナンアニュンジェーテメーダーヴィサラムブッダナサーサナン
従ってブッダの教えを念じて
念じてというのは思って考えて大事にして
信と道徳を身に付け 法
真理を知ることに喜びを感じることに智者は励むのですと
俗世間の金儲けじゃなくて
本当の財産に智者は励みますよと
で まあそれで終了 あれは経典の結論です
それで経典は終わり ウッガ経典は
で ちょっと私の感想ですね
忘れてしまった命 欲に溺れて
俗世間の富と名誉を得るために人間は必死でした
悪結果を顧みることもしないで
物質的な発展に必死でした
しかし 人生はさらに苦しくなるだけで
楽になること 平和になったことは未だにありません
我々はこの道ではどんどん悪くなるだけ
自然破壊するは 戦争はどんどん危なくなるは
とっても貧富の 貧富の差がどんどん広げていくは
どうなるかわからない世界なんですよ
なのに自分の生き方 論理的か
具体的か 理にかなっているか
目的に達しているかは気にしない
未だにこの生き方に対して気にしないんですね
まあその通りやりましょう
みんなと一緒にやりましょうとか
みんなやることやりましょうという
そればっかりで 何かが忘れているんです
ブッダが人は忘れてしまった
一度も発見しなかったことなんですけど
その真の宝物を七つにして完全に発表なさったんです
だから我々も今の子供たちも何か忘れているという感じがあるでしょうに
学校に行って無茶苦茶勉強しなくても
なんかこれでいいのかとか
必死で仕事してこれでいいのかと
何かみんな感じていますよ
豊かになるほどなるほど
なんかすごい穴を感じているんです
精神的に それで じゃあ道徳を学ばなくちゃ
あれもあれもと なんだ無茶苦茶暗りで
もうあちこちあちこち手を伸ばしても全然見つからないんですね
この忘れてしまったものは何なのかと
お釈迦様がそれは七つの宝物を忘れているんだよと
これあればあのこの穴がなくなっちゃうんです
だから人類は今に 今歩んでいる道を完全にやめて
この七つの宝物を獲得する道を歩まなくちゃいけないんです
そう歩むと貧乏になると思いますか？逆です
みんな豊かになるんです
金が勝手に入ってくるんだけど
金は一時的で もうもう捨てるものだと
ものすごい気持ち悪い感じでいるんです
人間でいる間でも幸福で
死んじゃってもそこでまた幸福でということになるんです
不幸にさせようと思っても誰にもできない
それから自分自身のものだから
一体ですからね 例えば知識であろうが知恵であろうが
もう確信であろうが 自分のものでしょう
誰にも盗ることできるんでしょう
それで火にも燃えない
火に燃えないでしょうに
水に流せないでしょうに
王様はそれに政府が税金つけますかね
あなたの道徳にこれぐらい税金かかるぞとか
それで話は終わります
うん まあとにかくこの現代社会である
この経済的に豊かに また豊かでない貧富のあらゆる世界に対して
何かみんな本当の宝物を忘れているんだよと
その本当の宝物を得るために頑張ってくださいと
またそれは真理ですから
誰にも違うとは言えるはずはないんです
言っても ただまあ感情を言うだけで
別に論理的にしっかりと言うことはできないんです
はい 以上です どうもありがとうございます
はい  [終礼]